[Music]
news roundup international edition he's
callin O'Brien and Andy Richter first
Bruce and Marianne could you put some
cheesy foreign anchor suits on us please
thank you nice
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right last seven tonight's top story
out of Greece weirdo background guy
strikes again
I'm actually the exhibit I would look at
the next opinion and in Taiwan another
story from the slide reporter
[Applause]
and out of nowhere in the UK this
happened it does take quite a long time
to make change be we the best one in the
world
and II Japanese people continue to do
stuff like this
Spanish unemployment and utter boredom
led to this
[Music]
and Bolivia is highly in need of
criminal sketch artists UN rato a Vlado
the king ambhi a comment IDO este
thank you Andy in Germany this guy
should have had more for breakfast
infamous you wanna give a big booty his
mama
that's okay well the man takes happen
telephone game heaven and this Russian
reporter should have had less to drink
but she wasn't mad at him I thought that
I would now Andy has international
sports and weather in the Czech Republic
a hockey player was asked the longest
question ever the other if they know not
so let's get them to mock reporters it's
all in school so you said tickled about
two minutes ago and I well can put and I
every unless the hell do democracy and
in weather England was attacked by
millions of sperm look out England
Gary situation a and now a weird
Japanese commercial for an
incomprehensible product
[Music]
next-step
European health tip with dr. Vittorio
dinelli
people ask me how much you should have
my six-year-old drink I say let them
drink as much as they want kids gotta
have wine and finally no matter where
they were on the planet Americans
continued to represent us with pride
that was your local news roundup
international with Conan O'Brien and
Andy Richter just like this every night
[Applause]